today in England witchcraft and it's
more modern incarnation Wicca are pagan
religions Wiccans worship the gods and
spirits of nature in return for their
faith the spirits grant them the power
of magic it was this power that first
drew dailies cod2 Wicca now she's
studying to become a full-fledged witch
I like the name which and I suppose
anyway I'd like to reclaim it as being a
good word and a standing for all the
things that I believe in she has her
husband's complete support though he has
no interest in witchcraft himself she
knows others will not be so accepting
I'm very careful about who I tell I'm
very careful about he sees my pentacle
heritage that sits by me and I have a
great belief that it should be next to
my my body as opposed to on show so
there's a lot of prejudice still once a
month Kaylee's meets with her coven a
group of like-minded witches who bolster
one another in their faith they call
themselves the Raven and the rose
okay when witches gather in a circle
they believe they can weave stronger
magic sure procreation festival tonight
will be gay Lisa's first time
participating in a secret ritual red
sandalwood for passion it's April
thirtieth tomorrow which is all over
England celebrate what they call the
first day of summer Beltane as High
Priestess of the Raven and the rose
Jeanette Ellis will lead her covens
Beltane rituals we're cooking up an
incense for Beltane making an incense is
a spell the different ingredients that
go into it like making a cake you blend
them all together and they all have
specific jobs within the cake or the
incense in this case and we'll burn that
tonight on Beltane the coven will thank
the guards for the Earth's renewed
fertility for witches only Halloween All
Hallows Eve is more sake we take the
energy of the goddess and God of earth
and air and fire and water the energies
of the universe I place within we your
dark and light ah yeah fire and water
find us or one let nothing impure enter
here in let no one be present unless
they come with an open heart their
rituals shows appreciation for the
return of summer and renewal homage paid
the witches can ask for their gifts from
the gods wish them luck then as with
holy day celebrations everywhere it's
time for the party to begin
foremost in England Beltane is known as
Mayday an ancient feast still celebrated
widely despite the fears their faith
still sparks which is figure in May Day
festivals across England the Raven and
the Rose coven seizes the opportunity to
march proudly through the streets their
public log shows that prejudice is
beginning to wane and reminds on lookers
that the celebration of the earth the
sky and the seasons is humankind's
oldest faith